silikon implantate an gespitzte ohren
eine gespaltene zunge
der anblick irritiert und weckt viel
argwohn
caracciolo ist 25 jahre alt und betreibt
ein eigenes tattoo und piercing studio
in zürich
sie hat schon viele body modification an
ihrem körper gemacht
was treibt menschen zu solch massiven
eingriffen an ihrem körper die
psychologin ria kelling hat sich in
ihrer doktorarbeit mit der motivation
für body modification befasst paar
motive geschmiedet sich allen studien
und zwar ist es selbstverständlich
verschönerung von eigenen körper und
unterstrich für die individualität
die allermeisten zeigen dass körper der
körperschmuck body modification selbst
weggesteckt
aber auch das kann helfen negative
erlebnisse verarbeiten oder das kann
halt für einen negativen erlebnisse neue
bedeutung
schon immer haben menschen ihren körper
verändert
sei es aus spirituellen religiösen oder
aus gründen der stammeszugehörigkeit in
vielen kulturen haben solche
körperlichen eingriffe auch die funktion
der disziplinierung und unterordnung vor
allem die frauen nach vielen
generationen kann daraus ein
schönheitsideal entstehen als tragender
bestandteil einer kultur in unseren
kreisen erscheinen die veränderungen am
körper dagegen eher beliebig wenn es um
selbstverwirklichung geht ist fast alles
erlaubt
einzigartig sein um jeden preis jeder
mensch ist zwangsläufig ein teil der
gesellschaft ob er will oder nicht
während die meisten wert auf anpassung
leben betonen andere radikal ihre
individualität straßen oder offenbar
nimmt man diese negativen folgen in kauf
die motivation ist stark und entspringt
letztlich einem gefühl des mannes
nämlich dass mit einer der
gesellschafter die not leiden ist jetzt
sehr virtuell ist und die küssen so
empfindlich kalt und doch hat das
bedürfnis fehler wieder wett machen
ausgestellt werden durch body
modification so wenn wir verbinden
wieder herstellt zwischen dem seelischen
und körperlichen doch was ist wenn sich
das innenleben wandelt mit den jahren
body modification sind kaum rückgängig
zu machen dass es menschen gibt die so
unbeschwerten dieser tatsache umgehen
irritiert wahrscheinlich am meisten
ja also ich natürlich als teenie
rebelliert mehr oftmals aber
unwahrscheinlich sind aber immer noch
das mit einem verbindungshaus dass
gaddafi
und weil ich den alten bereich was er
alles aber es geht als einfache aber
keine pause sind sondern haben sich
stelle
diese unbeirrbarkeit mark stutzig machen
doch vielleicht weckt der radikal zur
schau gestellte mut auch ein bisschen
bewunderung body modification geschieht
freiwillig und tut außer den betroffenen
niemandem weh deshalb ist toleranz
gefragt auf beiden seiten